[Music]
in darn kids news darn PR gosh darn it
dog got it okay hey kids now whoa
wait a minute I think we [ __ ] up
what's up punch him in the face every
day oh great
he's very serious submitted by crisp air
you know what it's really tempting you
guys are from LA dude any air is crisp
yeah exactly
yeah yeah anywhere's Chris have you seen
the mountains it let's be honest way
we're gonna go on the Sunday we're gonna
go guys want to go we're moving
what if you take like a whole like six
hour break we might go to Tahoe
you can meet some Tahoe dude that I've
never seen the mountains so covered in
snow that's what I want to go check it
out yeah just move another time you guys
want to take a little six hour break we
just got it just a drive there okay
really Christ Nick cuz it's a whole
bunch of winding yeah you get carsick
[ __ ] yeah we need to get a helicopter
can we get a JK hello hi hi
we haven't even read the freight of
private planes tenants of a luxury
apartment building are upset that it's
overrun with college students I get it
kids so kids do suck I need a quiet
suite is this seven one seven our old
building oh we we have a lot of college
students but it never feels like there
are it's not overrun with them oh but it
is a look your next-door neighbors when
we lived in downtown it was college
students and it wreaked of we'd like is
that a bad thing there was a ton of yeah
it's a little too much it was excessive
there was a ton of SU kids like the rich
is a USS do a ton of USC kids well is my
mind cuz we have some SC students in our
apartment - yeah and I'm just like how
do you guys [ __ ] it how does your
parents of or dish yeah I know you must
be so rich Oh [ __ ] semester because
I'm living there but I'm like damn dude
this is like I'm living here like that
means their parents have their own house
they're paying like [ __ ] thousands of
dollars and they might
would be an only child what's a doormat
SC coughs Thalia Gretel she big old girl
what cuz I feel I mean last time I
checked it was like 80 grand a year to
go let's guess what Jesus then Jesus
said that she is mine I was like you
know Jesus I'll take it
so you gotta pay 80 grand well yeah the
doorman
what's the dorm like a to Greenham I
don't know what the dorm is but I tell
you this my apartments don't come cheap
four thousand a month but that's only
ours cuz we're in the penthouse corner
largest one it's on our families are
like smaller apartments and are like two
grand but the part about the students on
earth that's why I wondered if the dorms
the same is to a door might be too you
know but two grand is still a lot to
give to a [ __ ] student to just live
it that's a house it's a lot of money
yeah yeah I slapped off walk out on my
kid if you ask me that [ __ ] Yeah right
you live in a heart there's some sticks
gonna make it yeah yeah daddy had a
[ __ ] fire that's all place to live in
you do too and then I go check it out
it's a crack house and I'm like we're
getting you a more decent place here's
the penthouse here the keys to the
penthouse there's like sirens and then
you walk up and there's a guy with a
[ __ ] heroin needle on his [ __ ] arm
and [ __ ] there's somebody like you want
to buy some guys you want to buy some
[ __ ] guns and I'm like this doesn't
seem like a great environment for my
daughter you can't study your candy
anyway so this takes place in Brooklyn
and we're talking about this building
called the Azur where a six hundred and
twenty eight square foot two-bedroom
apartment go for three thousand is good
yeah twice that's the size of art I mean
twice as much as ours
cuz we ran a 1400 square foot apartment
for 4,000 and that's half for the same
600
no York's wildman 600 style he's not
that expensive compared to New York or
San Fran
let's go New York even Boston yeah they
make LA feel yeah Ellie's like peasants
would read to them yeah back then yes
the building they struck a deal to rent
about 30% of their 150 units to a school
called King the King's College in lower
Manhattan and so tenants there are
[ __ ] pissed because they have
families and that's like a
bait-and-switch yeah this luxury
apartment oh by the way half of its like
gonna be a dorm now here's all day after
they moved in that they they did this
deal with this College so all these
residents that have families and so
they're just so mad because they're like
are you kidding me cuz they have a
rooftop and they're saying that there
was a whole bunch of like topless girls
just like sunbathe like you know we
don't with you this is an abomination
I'll be like can I go to the pool please
watch i watch I go out and then you're
already out there with the kids with
your titties Joe you go braless a lot
yeah I'll take it all I brought you you
would probably be with those that's
probably chair again and then they're
also in pajamas in the Commons how dare
they [ __ ] like if they're in college sir
probably taking a surfboard trying to
write it down the stairs
in their pajamas alcohol into the
commonplace coffins 18 year old college
people are crazy they punch right jump
off the balcony with umbrellas trying to
catch themselves in the wind like here's
a 29th floor
that's kind of yeah I lived in a college
town and like I just I just see madness
it is pure chaos yeah people like two
frat boys during our friends being one
of them's pretending to be a dog like I
mean we did stupid [ __ ] to they're just
crazy I I apart there's been some stuff
like I stole a stop sign but it's just a
lot of creep dude we set up a drum set
in the street corner at midnight and had
a jam session
yeah and no I would go visit him I had
my own apartment but then we were at his
college town because I don't live in a
college town but we did that we would
like we would bring hookahs down to the
jacuzzi and have meetings with our
hookah meeting yeah we just did stupid
[ __ ] that sounds pretty tame putting a
pudding having a [ __ ] live music
concert in the middle of the night and
on a street corner Spain is the worst
that's pretty crazy I'm eating other
things but I didn't want to mention
because they're illegal cuz also if you
have like families living around there
you don't want a drum set going off in
the middle of night I don't either if
I'm paying a lot of money I want to like
quiet and nice you know it was illegal
for them to tell you what type of
tenants are in the house cuz yeah we're
looking at the apartment I was like so
what kind of people live here and
they're like well we're technically not
allowed to say but they're young
professionals most mostly young
professional and I was like what you
can't say why cuz it's like it's like
yeah I'm like what like like if you tell
me like there's a lot of black people or
something and I'm like yeah like it's
taking a four to four thousand they're
not like exactly Isis gonna like yeah
because I just want to make sure that
I'm not around a bunch of people that
are gonna be loud all day and crazy we
had a lot of strippers in ours oh [ __ ]
yeah call them strippers huh call them
strippers I didn't know that they were
but then the electrical guy that would
fix things like he was telling us that
there's a cable guy or cable that you'd
like you guys know you know their
buildings full of strippers strippers he
was like yeah they'd have like I just
went and I did one like on whatever
floor is like there's a bunch money and
like clothes every launcher it's all in
the place like okay maybe could it's
near the strip club maybe just that's
convenient as a convenient commute for
that just like all the bankers they live
right there cuz it's so close same with
the strippers yeah so they're also
saying that they there they take over
the gym and then they have earbuds in
there
ears and they're like yelling at each
other to try to hear each other but then
they take over so then a lot of the
people that live there the residents
they're just like man it's doubled my
commute to work because I can't even go
downstairs and get an uber because there
are all these college students dating
yeah doing like beers then some of these
complaints are definitely valid some of
these complaints sound like an old
[ __ ] for be like they're yelling
each other with the earbuds on or
they're stealing my uber pajamas another
valid one I think is that they cause the
elevators to crawl so sometimes and then
that's what double is the time to get
downstairs
oh yeah 30 point yeah they're they're
going in between floors to visit each
other and so you never know how long
you're you know I get it there's a new
sense to life I've never been to like a
college dorm it's just crazy it's not a
pleasant place to look yeah I would
wander a family person
they should have apartments based off of
your lifestyle then it's like they'll be
more so there are some apartments maybe
it's just Sacramento but they like in
this is not that but kind of like yeah
it's like you pay what you afford like
it's based on your salary
it's like how they do some of these art
laughs they have lost order for like
artists kinda like you said like well
you know like on this our street inside
how about here od they're all art loss
in that and then it's based on what you
make so you I think you have to prove
what you make and then they take 15% of
that or whatever like all right you're
gonna pay 2 grand you're gonna play 3
grand it's coming and you all know there
are we don't have the percentage I think
it's a percent I might be wrong but it
is based on what you make somehow and
then they have our communities here
where you have to apply an interview to
get in and it's a community of artists
bishop for some doctors it's like if I'm
a doctor and I live without the dog
maybe cuz I know they're gonna have a
similar lifestyle to me or something I
don't know well I don't know cuz you
might have one doctor that loves his
hookers true and beloved doctor that's
just super celibate like he's like man
you just [ __ ] hookers all day it's
loud you guys have me oh you shouldn't
live in a apartment if you're gonna feel
like it's a doctor you're gonna have
like a mansion or something you're not
gonna be in apartment what if it's close
to us back in New York there's no houses
we got this one member a barbell he's a
doctor and every year he goes on [ __ ]
hookers and he comes in high all the
time and he's the only one watson sandal
you all
so I never go to him I would never even
think it yeah you wouldn't never he's
off [ __ ] a lover but isn't that good
though cuz he's releasing all of his
tension and stress yeah so then he could
focus and do his surgery very quick he's
really cool hmm
I'm a surgeon he's weak I'm just hoping
that he is like yeah I side with these
guys cuz I just know at different stages
in life you make different decisions and
you want a certain lifestyle and you
just don't want to see crazy yeah cuz
imagine like senior living homes but I
like there's a typically age restricted
yeah they are you can't be a certain
unless you're like living there to
assist your parents or whatever it is it
is hard to like you said like some
doctors probably do like strippers and
below and some doctors like to like
chill you like you can't do it by
occupation because there's always gonna
be variants and you can't really do it
by age because there's a huge variance
like I'm 30 tons of people I like to
drink and I like to just sleep one
should be like like like senior yeah
quiet tower or like family moderate
really scale of 1 to 10 how louder
animal owner tower likes smoking
non-smoking maybe like dog older tower
yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz if you don't
have a dog and there's [ __ ] dogs
growing up in that I like dogs so I
don't care but me neither if you hated
dogs and they're running up and down
you're freaking yeah yeah like when I
was in college I was super studious and
I stayed in the dorm for the summer and
so I wasn't a party I'm always kept it
like really quiet but then I think about
what I did now and I think that was kind
of [ __ ] up we're out of buddy that
visited me and he was often I don't have
anywhere to park my motorcycle and I was
like oh just bring it upstairs and park
in front of my in front of my room
so we wheeled a motorcycle into the dorm
room and we took it up the elevator into
my hallway while the whole thing is just
fuming still so even though I wasn't
like a party on yeah you're an idiot if
there were kids on that floor they'd be
like why the [ __ ] is there a motorcycle
if I was trying to protect the homie
[Music]